36 years ago
and as far as I'm because my man thinks
I'm fat now because I put on four pounds
so I've got to lose that four pound yeah
I mean because I was full pan heavier
but as far as I'm concerned if the women
there and they're eating they're eating
they're eating they're eating they're
eating they don't want to help
themselves leave them right or if not
and you're married keep on feeding them
and just ensure her buy all the
fattening foods going just kill her off
and just let me die natural causes and
claim the money back
so okay so do he should leave his wife
if she starts sleeping with him
what else what other reasons What which
thing if she can't cook as she can't
clean because she can't it's the right a
woman needs to do all of them things
before you put a ring on her finger if
the woman can't cook take home to Mommy
but no she needs to learn how to cook I
had to clean and money she needs to know
how to sort out her finances not like oh
I've got a bill I'm going to go to Daddy
do you need to sort of because too many
women waste money and the women the men
let them waste the money and then they
waste all their money and then they want
to go and spend the men's well yeah
women own 70 to 80 of Consumer Debt even
though they um they make less money a
bit nine out of ten women got clothes in
the in the closet that's still got tags
on yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah see men
don't do that and women buy stuff that's
fashionable every time they want to
renew the fashion men buy classic
clothes that they can wear this year
next year the year after but women just
women just waste money you want a woman
that's good with money good in bed good
with children can cook was it a chef in
the kitchen
a [__] in the bedroom a nanny
and a cleaner that woman's got to be I
think there's about five different
things that you want in one woman guys
how did that how does that sound to you
I just no it's a feedback on what she's
saying no no it sounds good and and like
look to be honest yeah I don't think
it's asking much
you know it's not it's not over and
beyond for those things you know the
basic things like you said cooking
cleaning just
like and if you've been raised a certain
way you would have been you would have
known that naturally anyway do you know
what I mean and then you bring that into
a relationship to be honest the best
sort of raised women no matter what
country they're from are those that are
raised to be transitional yeah exactly
so when they come into the relationship
oh uh can you cook it's a standard to
work can you roll a dumpling can you do
food of course you've got to take off
your fingers for do you wear gloves for
season me come on there you go even even
on a black level even little things like
can you pla do you know what I mean
little things like that it's like
if they tend to come with no it's like
who raised you type of thing so by the
time you've got there you've got two
three four of the things naturally
already because women seem to think it's
like oh because like you know men want
me because I look good because I earn a
lot of money because I got a job I got a
car I got men don't want that they just
want someone
can I say something as a man sorry to
cut you off we do lack women that look
good we like attractive women yeah but
if I'm gonna be honest most of us don't
want a baddie I know it looks that way I
know things like social media or IG and
even some of the things men say even
you know the whole sort of uh Urban
hip-hop not even the hip-hop Black
Culture it's like we want baddies and
all that but realistically we don't want
we don't need to have a tent most men
will tell you we'll take if you want to
rate a six
seven on the looks scale but all the
other like the boxes you said as long as
they've got those we can go with that
like we were saying earlier
it it's not great to see but men do they
marry relationship if you want to say
the word settle and not the worst kind
of text we do so if she looks good on
top bonus and the sex should be you know
a standard thing yeah good thing dude
good sex and to be honest as a woman
don't you know it's there's this whole
notion that only men like sex and I'm
one of those people but any any person
I've had sex with in my whole life
whether it be relationship or even a
one-night stand as far as I'm concerned
she wants me as well it's not just I
want to just smash her and she just let
me I love it do you watch it I wanted to
do you would have thought it would be a
yeah it's like an equal value exchange
but women treat it like it's not exactly
and and you know what's interesting like
some of the language we have in society
always takes accountability off of the
women like for example he knocked her up
even in the church like the the girls
will always be like oh I was so broken I
was so light no you're a horny shut up
shut up
and now you found God it's convenient at
29.
not so
um question people in the chat want
everyone to rate them on a scale of one
to ten rate themselves
oh
yeah
on a good day like I feel like I'm a
strong seven seven
I'll give myself a six six
seven eight seven eight what were you
writing one to ten yeah what looks are
we Luke okay six seven six seven six
I'm a four
no
auntie
okay I'm gonna Read Super chats
in my Heyday I would have said I was at
night I'm a Fool oh with nine in your
hay day yes let me you got pecs let me
see let me see you see them pictures I
think they're on um
YouTube oh we got a hundred dollar Super
Chat everyone
y'all y'all okay I'm trying to I'm
trying to move into a new apartment it's
gonna be big it's gonna be beautiful it
is tell them about the apartment how
nice is it
like talking to the bike Skyline
top floor views from the six not from
the one the E1 yo special he's special
oh it's beautiful and the color scheme
the furniture
yo we gonna do a little MTV Crips kind
of thing yeah yeah no it's it's actually
special but we're only doing the
apartment tour
on memberships so if you want to see it
you got to be in our second tier of
memberships which is the 10 tier I know
I'd share it with all of you
but I'm trying to get more members I'm
gonna be honest
I'm just I'm just you know
dollars it's not that much okay anyways
so thank you to Darby Jones for the 100
Super Chat thank you Auntie for top
shelf content you're getting so many
supers today they love you blowing up
top shelf ain't good what Top Shelf
ain't that like no it's good that's good
it's good that's good that's good yeah
I'm thinking nowadays you know when you
put things on the top shelf oh no top
notch think topmost guys we're gonna
work we're gonna work with Annie and
Auntie after we move and we're gonna
like get our little Channel set up so
we're gonna you're gonna get more
content from her um so mgtow by Logic
ladies on the couch are laughing but
Auntie is trying to save your life your
pee is worthless if you don't share it
with a man who loves you get off your
horse you're not special darkened flame
anti you're a fire preach keep telling
these secrets we need more females with
your commitment to honesty Ryan Morgan
and the video yesterday you talked about
how men mature later so how do you
recommend they pursue women when they
are 20 to 21 because the women that want
to settle down are looking for older men
focus on purpose
um yeah I mean yeah I would just say as
a guy like the more you build yourself
up the more girls want you so if you get
in the gym and you make more money girls
will come mgtow by Logic he might cheat
on me even but he might cheat on me even
if I bang him so I won't bang him just
in case chick logic is